what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest craziest developments
in the demon slayers story and believe
me these are probably the craziest
developments we've seen to date the
story is progressing at a blazing pace
if you enjoy seeing these weekly Demon
Slayer videos make sure to smash that
like button to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss new chapter reviews when they come
out for daily anime facts and to help
decide what demon slayer videos I make
in the future follow us on instagram at
anime uproar obviously there will be
manga spoilers in this video we are
talking about the latest chapter chapter
191 after all you've been warned
now without further ado let's jump into
it for the chapter cover we get an
awesome colored image of your Ichi the
strongest demon slayer in history with
his back to Tangier oh it's not
surprising that these characters are
being shown together because as we know
by now ton zero is a kind of successor
to your ichi yuri cheese breath of the
sun' style the first and strongest
breath style has been passed down
through tunnels family for generations
in the form of the dance of the fire-god
tangental now uses the dance of the
fire-god aka the breath of the sun in
battle in the past you each he told his
brother that there would be someone from
later generations who will surpass even
him and it really seems like that person
is destined to be our protagonist
tangelo Komodo who was the first to
awaken the demon ser mark the red sword
and learned a dance of the fire God
however he's been out cold for a while
so the fact that we're finally seeing
him on the cover suggests that he'll
wake up in this chapter we just had xeni
to inosuke and come I'll show up last
chapter so the fact that we could get to
see tundra in this chapter is amazing if
you'll remember in the last chapter
Mulan was doing pretty poorly against
the pillars and the demon slayers I
suggested that the tables would turn as
early as this chapter and let's see if I
was right this chapter is called which
one of us is the demon a very
interesting title of course Mulan is
supposed to be the only demon but this
chapter will in some way clearly
challenged a boundary between humans and
demons we immediately jump to you Shira
who is injecting tangelo with some of
the antidote scratch that with a lot of
the antidote
it seems like we're at eyes worried but
you should have tells him that Tangier
was poisoned by mousse on a long time
ago so he's in a specially bad condition
when compared to how the pillars were
two chapters ago I mentioned this and
how things looked especially bad for
tundra because his body has been exposed
to the poison for so frickin long thank
God that he's our protagonist so a part
of us should know that he'll survive
this seemingly unsurvivable situation
then we see a good sign
Murata tries to free tangent or from his
sword but tangelos hand won't let go of
it even though he's unconscious he
hasn't given up the will to fight we
also see tango coos flamed Suba aka
guard on tonzura sword which I love the
fire of the great lion Goku burns on and
he's still with us and spirit even
though he passed away many many chapters
ago suddenly they notice a pulse coming
from tangelo the pulse is weak but the
hype is real
this means we might see tundra open his
eyes soon and I say I in the singular
because the flesh destroying poison has
totally erased under those other eye by
this point I'm not going to lie he looks
absolutely terrible right now but at
least we are told that dawn is near they
are trying to get him up to defeat
Mouzon they say the others have cornered
Mouzon so they want hangzhou to help
finish him off just when it looks like
he won't wake up and you shiro is
thinking that it's no use because his
pulse is fading they hear a sound it's
tons of a sword and the next thing you
know tundra opens his eye finally his
last performance against Mouzon was
pretty anticlimactic but I'm sure that
he'll more than make up for it now then
we jump to moves on versus the pillars
and the demon slayers one of the weaker
members of the Demon Slayer core is
watching and he's impressed it looks to
him like the demon slayers might just do
it they might just last until dawn and
finally defeat moves on this is
definitely how it looked last chapter
moves on couldn't finish off the pillars
then he soon the rest showed up and
moves on even took a huge body shot from
gil maze wrecking ball now Sanne me
picks up one of the paper talismans
which makes him invisible and allows him
to see the other characters wearing the
paper talisman sonim is excited as usual
and he goes in to do some damage to
moves ons tentacles Yomi accesses the
see-through world to learn more about
moves on and some of his body's possible
weaknesses some of you wonder how
Guillaume a can see a see-through world
that he's blind but it can be accessed
through your others
answers for Guillaume a he listens
closely to reverberations and he can see
it that way he notices some stuff that
we figured out when we saw moves on
spite against uhé namely that he has
multiple brains and heart you can
obviously make more organs than one body
should be able to have yo may realizes
that this is the reason he won't die
when his head is cut his brains and
hearts don't even have fixed locations
rather they move making them even more
difficult to hit then Yomi gets a plan
he thinks that if the others can gain
access to the see-through world they may
be able to time an attack where they can
hit all 12 vital spots at the same time
and thus win they don't know at this
point that musong can explode into over
1,800 pieces and regenerate later from a
fraction of the pieces only tundra got a
glimpse of that when he saw the demon
king of pops fight against your ichi
something really cool proceeds to happen
yo Mei tells my boy eager awake a little
Orochimaru to look closely at Mouzon
amazingly that it's enough for eager to
glimpse the see-through world for a
moment this adds even more credence to
how strong ego really is I feel like a
lot of people sleep on iguras talent but
he's been killing it during this battle
and now he's one of the talented few to
see the see-through world just when
things seem at their worst for Mouzon we
get a full page of his tentacles going
crazy and destroying the area around him
the weaker member of the demon sea
record I was watching hears the sound of
this attack insensitive shaking he
checks on the fighting and see something
shocking
almost everyone looks dead the tables
have been turned that fricking quickly
even I didn't think that the change
would be so sudden but moves on took out
the strongest pillars yo Mason ami gue
gue Rose any Tzu and eNOS care all badly
injured it looks like Yomi lost his left
leg his right arm and the others could
have been wounded justice seriously this
is insane
it reminds me when you should are used
genjutsu on knocking me and moves on so
that I looked like a guru and Mitsui
were defeated and badly wounded the
sudden switch is similar to we didn't
get to see exactly how everyone got hit
well we see they're already severely
damaged bodies of course I don't think
this is genjutsu
not he may should be dead ushiro was
helping ton zero and the idea that he'd
get close to moves on is unrealistic and
last but not least I don't think the
mangaka would try to pull the same thing
twice this
the injuries are real and the defeated
include the strongest pillars like Gil
Mei and Sunnah me Cano appears to be the
last human still conscious
she thinks that moves on is too fast and
you can see how scared she is we have a
panel with her on her knees and her
blade is broken she's powerless and
moves on is looming over her it really
seems like the end for Cano
she's completely outmatched here kinda
was trying to convince herself to stand
up she's thinking to herself that she
must defeat him she must ensure that the
other butterfly estate girls can live in
peace moves on and his demons are
responsible for the deaths of their
families and a deaths of Shinobu and
kana she is ready to die she wants to
beat him even if it kills her she wants
to bravely avenge everyone's death and
prevent future suffering then the weaker
member of the Demon Slayer Corps who was
watching before starts running to
connell yelling stop it - moves on moves
on obviously doesn't care or notice and
raises his arm preparing to give a
finishing blow just then all hype
limiters explode Mouzon gets attacked by
a move called beneficent radiance moves
ons
arm that was raised as cut off he's
shocked he looks in the distance and
sees tangelo he has rescued Carmel and
quickly taken her away to the member of
the Demon Slayer core so he can keep her
safe
Colonel has tears in her eyes and Tantra
assures her that it's him and he
apologizes for being late does this
remind anyone else of when egora took
Mitsui to safety in my house strongest
kind of video I talked about some
reasons I shipped hunter and Cano and
Wow after this chapter I'll have to say
it's all aboard moves on approaches
Tonto and tells him that he looks
positively awful the right side of his
face is consumed by Mullins flesh
destroying poison this is probably why
Kunal was in part concerned while
looking at Tangier oh and why he had to
confirm that it was indeed him when time
sure looks that moves on he looks
horrible but he also looks determined to
win
he looks scarier than moves on and I'm
sure moves on is shaking in his boots
right about now he even says that it's
hard to tell which one of them is the
demon moves on gets a glimpse of your
Ichi again inviting comparisons between
the two breath of the Sun users moves on
the big bad villain of the series tells
Tangier oh that is making his skin crawl
while conjurer seems completely calm and
says let's finish this Musa and that is
the end of one of the craziest and most
epic chapters ever
Wow I knew muslem would turn the tables
and tundra would be needed but I had no
idea it would all happen so fast keep in
mind we're still waiting on a Zuko so
she could come into play soon right now
though it definitely seems like
pendulous destiny to defeat mulan as
your ichi successor is definitely coming
into fruition one question is does
Tundra just look like a demon or is he
actually becoming a demon with a demon
power boost of his own how strong is
Tundra now since he didn't succeed in
doing much before he fell into a coma
ask sleep how strong is awaken tangelo
he seems to be extremely strong he
appears to be in his selfless state he's
not insulting moves on or getting overly
emotional he's just matter-of-factly
telling him that it's time for them to
finish this if we remember against occas
a Tundra selfless state put him ahead of
akka so temporarily not cuz I couldn't
stop him from cutting off his head even
though he knew he was coming since
Tundra told him he'd cut off his head
before he did it in the selfless state
Tundra doesn't give off hatred or
killing intent so ah cos I couldn't
sense him coming and was caught
completely off-guard when times will cut
his arm this time time sure proved that
he can similarly catch moose on the
strongest demon off-guard and cut his
arm off chances are though that Tong
shows power has escalated even further
since his awakening there's obviously a
reason he had to pass out he needed to
unlock the new power through those
flashbacks he probably won't develop
demon powers although that would be kind
of cool but he likely learned how to
fight better from watching a TV through
his ancestors memories he could have
even unlocked or remembered the
thirteenth breath of the Sun move by now
which has been hyped up as a key to
beating Mouzon now there appears to be
no doubt awakened tangental has
surpassed the pillars and it even looks
like he surpassed the strongest pillar
Guillaume a who was taken out by Mouzon
it's still too early though to assume
that he surpassed yuuichi even though
you teach he did suggest that someone
probably tonnes it off would surpass him
eventually it's interesting that Tundra
has now become the Goku of the series
previously llame was set up as the Goku
of the serious meaning he usually comes
in the nick of time and gives everyone
present a sense of relief and the
feeling that everything will be alright
however he was taken out by Mouzon and
tundra is now the one serving that role
he rescued Kongo in the nick of time and
gave her and oz hope that moves on
could be stopped let me know what you
think is going to happen with Dungeness
horrible wound will he died defeating
moves on or will nesic will be able to
help cure him it's an interesting choice
to have punch it or fight against moves
on alone at this point of course he
might get help later but so far it's
always been a team effort except when
you eat she was fighting it appears now
that the other pillars and demon Slayers
are so hurt that Tanja will have to have
a 1vs1 stand against mousse on this one
versus one set up goes to further mirror
moves ons fight against your Ichi we saw
this mirroring happen when Mouzon looked
at tangelo and saw your ichi moves on is
scared the tundra will finish what your
ichi started and that is exactly what it
looks like will happen and that is it
for today's chapter review if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
weekly chapter reviews make sure to
smash that like when to let me know turn
it blue like you sword if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification belt where you
will miss future videos when they come
out for daily anime facts and to help
decide what videos I make in the future
flawless on instagram at anime uproar
link in the description demon slayers
one of my favorite series of all time
and we are experiencing probably the
most exciting part of the entire story
right now I just want to say that I am
super grateful that I get to experience
it as it happens together with you it's
awesome that we can all experience this
amazing work of art together a special
thank you goes out to our patrons over
on patreon who help us survive YouTube
issues and who helped make videos like
this one possible especially want to
thank our pro hero to your patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson king's address $30 beat
Anatolia Cassatt's key alpha do angel
Cruz team Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan
Kapoor Jessica Maloney and pro taco and
Timothy Edward Vargas and are the one to
your patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Stephan and Radha a Lola autumn
makoto-kun
the world stealers the school bus and
Tyson quarry no thank you all so much if
you enjoy our work you can support more
by going over to patreon.com slash
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do soil your
name featured in future videos alongside
these epic people right here
and you'll even get access to her
private patron only discord where we
talked about anime life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
slash anime uproar link in the
description if you're interested you can
also now join the YouTube channel and
support more content that way if you
prefer whichever way you choose to
support us you will get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see you space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]